I'm joined today by Abigail Marsh who's
an associate professor of psychology and
neuroscience at Georgetown University
also author of the book The Fear Factor
how one emotion connects altruist
Psychopaths and everyone in-between so
Abigail to get us into this topic let's
first sort of try to get everybody on
the same page in terms of when we say
psychopathy and that someone is a
psychopath what are we talking about I'm
glad you asked that because there's a
ton of misconceptions about psychopathy
um it's not an official clinical
diagnosis it's considered a personality
disorder and it's a constellation of a
number of personality traits that hang
together one of which is in the sort of
signature one of which is a kind of
callous uncaring personality and a
tendency not to experience remorse after
having done something wrong and you also
have traits that also tend to go with
that like manipulative nests
deceitfulness and sometimes
impulsiveness as well and when we talk I
mean and you can answer this generally
about personality disorders or more
specifically about psychopathy how much
do we consider or how much do we know
about how much nature versus nurture
play into these personality disorders
it's a really important question the
estimate for how heritable psychopathy
is comes from quite a few studies now
usually on twins who are either
identical or fraternal and those studies
suggest that variation and psychopathic
traits is about sixty percent due to
genetic factors with the rest being due
to sort of idiosyncratic environmental
factors and does that mean in in late
I'm sorry in layman's terms could that
mean that one might have a
predisposition to psychopathy that might
or might not manifest depending on
environmental conditions absolutely
that's exactly what it means so it means
that things that you inherit from your
parents you know temperamental traits
for example fearlessness there's a very
good study recently showing that the
fearlessness of the biological mother
predicts fearlessness and the biological
child which then
goes on to predict callous and uncaring
traits later on but that those traits
can absolutely be mitigated or affected
by all sorts of other things that happen
for example how warm and caring the
mother is so what are the sort of
activities or what we might consider
flags of possible psychopathic
tendencies in kids and what's the
earliest point at which those might be
observed we think that there might be
markers of psychopathic traits that can
be reliably detected as early as maybe 2
or 3 one of the things I study is how
sensitive people are to others fear and
we know that children who are unusually
callous and uncaring already are showing
weaknesses and identifying others fear
by age 2 or 3 and if we're all sort of
fearless temperament coupled with sort
of a callous responsiveness to other
people's distress I tend to be the early
risk factors for psychopathy luckily
things like temper tantrums hitting
people when you're angry those are not
early signs of psychopathy those are for
better for words just normal toddler
behaviors yeah that's interesting I mean
in your work do you sometimes have
parents who are worried that their child
might be exhibiting psychopathic
tendencies who are just not and it
causes significant concern for the
parents oh absolutely you know parents
will you know discover that their child
is biting other children at preschool or
having this horrible temper tantrums and
or terrified that their child is some
sort of a monster but the you know the
reality is that most two and
three-year-olds are sort of monsters at
least some of the time and you know for
the most part they all learn to control
their behavior later on the only
children that you really want to worry
about are children who seem to sort of
and generally fearless across the board
and and it's easy to confuse
fearlessness with boldness so for
example my child loved to climb high
structures to explore them when she was
younger and people would say was she so
fearless and of course I said no she's
nobody because I've seen her in the dark
and I've seen her in the water and she's
actually quite fearful in other
circumstances but she did love to
explore and so that was why she would
climb on these
climber's the bigger concern is children
who are fearless across contacts they
don't seem to be afraid of anything I've
worked with adolescents who when I asked
them to report the last time they felt
really frightens told me that they never
felt friend of anything and that's
that's pretty unusual so as early as two
or three you can start to see some of
these tendencies when we're talking
about a 5 7 or 9 year old in in your
experience what are some of the
behaviors that you might start to see so
that's a tricky age because most of the
instruments that are used for assessing
callous and unemotional traits as
they're called in children are not
really designed for assessing children
not young because some of Eric turistic
behaviors that you'll you'll see later
on haven't really started developing
quite so young so admittedly it's a
really difficult age to pin anything
down for sure but again what I would be
looking for is again it's sort of
generally fearless temperament sort of
insensitivity to any kind of threat and
that also means insensitivity of
punishment this is one of the reasons
that psychopathy is associated with so
many problems is because in normal
children and in most people if you
believe that you're going to be punished
for doing something fear of getting
punished is what stops you from doing it
not every time maybe depending on how
fun that thing seems like it might be
but in general it has some effect on you
but if you don't experience fear
strongly you're not going to be worried
at all about possible punishments for
what you're doing and so Truman pervy
assess to punishment is definitely
troubling for a number of reasons is
there some generally accepted set of
questions that could be sort of a test
for psychopathy in the way that you have
you know the six questions to figure out
if someone might be depressed for
example or something along those lines
well so the newest version of the
Diagnostic and Statistical Manual in
psychiatry has included this little four
item specifier that is used to assess
again what are called callous
unemotional traits or
pro-social emotions in children who are
already having significant behavior
problems so among children who are
having significant behavior problems and
there are a lot of reasons that could be
many children who act out and are
aggressive and disruptive did not have
these traits but the indicators for the
ones that do include things like not
showing empathy or remorse not seeming
to care about outcomes like how well you
do in school or how your friendships are
going and having sort of flat effect
although again in general it seems to be
most relevant whether the child is
fearful or fearless so I instinctively
mitigate the possible negative
repercussions of psychopathy or what
what can be done it's it's true that
when it comes to personality disorders
you're not looking for a sort of a whole
overhaul of person's personality but um
certainly there are ways that you can
work with children to help them develop
and more adaptive ways there haven't
been that many really stringently tested
methods for improving in particular
these sort of callous and uncaring
traits and children
there aren't any particular
pharmaceuticals that are developed for
it although many children with these
traits are treated with pharmaceuticals
used for other disorders so for example
many of these children get stimulants
that are used for ADHD some of them
getting into psychotics that are used
for obviously psychosis and sometimes
those medications seem to have some
effects although I think often times
they're being used just because nobody
can think of what else to do
so I'm not a clinician myself and this
is not at all be officially recommending
them I'm just saying that's what's used
in terms of behavioral treatment there
are definitely a number of
good parenting training programs out
there in the world that teach parents
how to be more consistent and how to
focus on using reward and reinforcement
for shaping kids behavior which is
generally a better way to parent anyways
kids tend to respond better to reward
reward than they do to punishment and
that works for children who have these
traits as well I in reading articles
including articles that you're quoted in
you know in preparation for our
interview as I read about some of the
interventions that I done that that are
sometimes done I couldn't help but
wonder are we really mitigating the
psychopathic tendencies or are we
basically teaching how to manipulate
others responses by sort of knowing how
not to appear to be psychopathic I don't
know if you have a strong feeling on
that well for a long time it was
believed that psychopathy was truly
incurable and I don't think many people
would argue that anymore there there
must be a way to to improve it it's just
maybe we haven't hit on a really
effective way to do it yet I mean I
should also say that the older child is
when you first start treatment and the
more severe their symptoms the less
likely it is to work for children who
their problems are more moderate and
they're younger often times you can have
pretty good outcomes so there you there
have been studies showing that for
example group therapy for children you
have really severe antisocial behavior
may actually backfire because you're
sort of they're learning from each other
how to be better offenders and so this
is a concern that has been raised before
I mean the main problem with people who
were strongly psychopathic is that they
also tend to be fairly narcissistic
meaning they tend to think they're great
I've worked with children with these
traits before and one of the questions
that we've asked them in the past is to
just assess themselves on a scale from
one to ten with ten being I feel amazing
about myself and one being I feel
terrible about myself and at a typical
kid when you ask them to answer that
question will respond with like a seven
or an eight
and again we're screening out children
who have depression or anxiety who might
give a lower score on any case when we
asked children who have psychopathic
traits to answer the same question and
again these are kids who
you know don't have any real friends
have been thrown out of multiple schools
their parents are afraid of them
you know objectively speaking their life
is not going that well but they'll tend
to answer this question with you know 10
Miley's I was even like 11 or 20 and
that's a big problem because if you want
somebody to change them thinking that
they're as great as they could possibly
be is not a great starting point and so
just getting people motivated to change
is a really difficult stumbling block
unfortunately how common is the often
sort of caricature or stereotype of the
psychopathic kid of harming animals how
common is that in reality uh yeah that
is that definitely corresponds to risk
for psychopathy absolutely it sort of
depends on the age because in younger
children there may not be real
understanding you know if you think of
like a very small child you know burning
ants with a magnifying glass or
something I mean you could argue that
they may not really understand what it
is that they're doing but mistreating
animals you know pass through early very
early school age especially animals that
can obviously signify that they're in
pain or that they are suffering is
definitely a really serious problem the
book is the fear factor how one emotion
connects altruist psychopaths and
everyone in between we've been speaking
with the book's author Abigail Marsh
thank you so much for talking to us
about this thanks very much for having
me